.
>>> HELLO EVERYONE, AND WELCOME
BACK TO YOUR "FANTASY FIRE
DRILL," I'M MATT CAMP BACK WITH
YOU AND WE WILL GET YOU READY
FOR THE 2021 FANTASY FOOTBALL
SEASON AND LEAD YOU TO ANOTHER
CHAMPIONSHIP.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO HERE.
WE WILL BE TAKING YOUR
QUESTIONS.
YOU HAVE BEEN SUBMITTING THEM.
KEEP THEM GOING IN THE BR APP, I
WILL BE TALKING ROOKIES AND
INJURIES AND SO IN MUCH MORE,
TODAY AND FOR THE NEXT THREE
THURSDAYs AT 1:00 P.M. EASTERN.
WE WILL GET YOU READY, KEEP YOUR
DYNASTY QUESTIONS AND TRADES AND
WE WILL MONITOR EVERYTHING GOING
DOWN, LEAD HING IN TO WEEK ONE
THE REGULAR SEASON.
THE COWBOYS IN THE DEFENDING
TAMPA BAY BUCCANEERS.
BEFORE WE GET TO ALL OF THAT, AS
YOU ARE PREPARING YOUR DRAFT
BOARDS, YOUR RANKINGS, WHAT YOUR
TEAMS MAY LOOK LIKE, YOU MAY
WANT TO HAVE SOME ROOKIES ON
THAT TEAM.
YOU SHOULD NEVER SHY AWAY FROM
ROOKIES IN FANTASY FOOTBALL
BECAUSE OPPORTUNITY KNOCKS FOR
SOME OF THE PLAYERS AND THEY CAN
BE IMMEDIATE CONTRIBUTORS.
SO WHAT I WANT TO DO IS TALK
ABOUT THE ROOKIES THA RANKINGS.
I WILL REVEAL MY RUNNING BACK
RANKS LATER ON, NEW FACES AND IN
PLACES.
LET'S START WITH THE ROOKIES
THAT I LIKE RIGHT NOW IN MY TOP
100 RANKINGS.
HALF POINT PPR, WE WILL START
WITH NAJA HARRIS, THE FIRST
ROUND DRAFT PICK OF THE
STEELERS.
HE IS COMING TO A STEELER TEAM
THAT WANTS TO GET BACK TO RUN
ARE THE FOOTBALL.
BEN ROETHLISBERGER HAS BEEN IN
THE LEAGUE SINCE 2004, IT'S A
NICE WIDE RECEIVER GROUP, NO
DOUBT.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE RUNNING
BACKS HERE, THE TEAM HAS
STRUGGLED, WHETHER IT WAS SNELL
OR SAMUELS, HARRIS BEING A FIRST
ROUND DRAFT PICK SAYS HE WILL BE
THERE FROM DAY ONE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE STEELER OFFENSE.
RB-13 FOR ME IN MY RANKINGS AND
23rd OVERALL.
>>> LET'S MOVE DOWN AND TALK
ABOUT ANOTHER RUNNING BACK.
WE WILL GO DOWN TO JACKSONVILLE,
AND TALK ABOUT TRAVIS ENTIEM.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT, BUT
TRAVIS, RB-22 FOR ME, 44IT ITTH
OVERALL, I THINK HE WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT PASS CATCHER.
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF THE
PASSING GAME FOR THE
JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS AND IT
COULD MORPH IN TO A BIGGER ROLE.
HOW ABOUT IN CINCINNATI JOE
BURROW COMING BACK FROM INJURY.
A.J. GREEN IS GONE.
YES, THEY HAVE BOYD, AND THEY
HAVE HIGGENS AND MIXON, BUT
CHASE IS A DANGEROUS PLAYER, HE
IS MY WIDE RECEIVER 21 AND 49TH
OVERALL.
SO, YES, I THINK HE IS A WIDE
RECEIVER TOO ON THE LOW END FOR
FANTASY FROM DAY ONE.
LET'S GO OUT WEST, LET'S GO OUT
TO THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ers.
KYLE SHANAHAN, I WILL SAY THIS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN, LOVES YOUR
FANTASY TEAM.
ALWAYS A FANTASY FRIENDLY
OFFENSE.
AND THE RUNNING BACK POSITION,
IF YOU CAN EVER FIGURE OUT WHO
IT IS, HAS ALWAYS BEEN
PRODUCTIVE UNDER KYLE SHANAHAN
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ers.
RB-24, 50TH OVERALL, I'M AWARE
THAT RAHEEM NOMOSER IS STILL
THERE, QUESTION AT THE
QUARTERBACK POSITION, WE WILL
GET TO IT.
BUT I BELIEVE TREY SERMON, IF HE
IS NOT THE GUY FROM THE JUMP, HE
SHOULD BE A LOW END RB-2 FOR ME.
NOW, ONE OF THE BIGGEST ROOKIE
WHO IS CAN MAKE AN IMMEDIATE
IMPACT IS PLAYING FOR THE
ATLANTA FALCONS AND THAT IS KYLE
PITTS.
JULIO JONES IS IN TENNESSEE, WE
WILL GET TO IT COMING UP IN A
BIT.
KYLE PITTS IS THE MAN FOR THE
ATLANTA FALCONS AT THE TIGHT END
POSITION.
RIDLEY WILL BE GREAT, TOP FIVE
WIDE RECEIVER WE ALL KNOW THAT.
TO ME, KYLE PITTS IS STEPPING IN
WHERE THE FALCONS WILL BE
THROWING IT A LOT.
WE WILL TALKING ABOUT MIKE DAVIS
IN THE BACK FIELD.
THE TUOPPORTUNITY IS TOO GREAT R
KYLE PITTS AND HE WILL BE A
TOUGH PLAYER TO COVER,
ESPECIALLY WHEESPECIAL
LY WHEN RIDLEY IS ON THE FIELD
AS WELL.
>>> IS IT GOING TO GEL IN 2021?
A FAIR QUESTION.
BUT IT CLEARED UP A LITTLE BIT
WITH THE MOVES IN THE
OFF-SEASON, MELVIN GORDON IS
STILL THERE AND NOW ENTERS
JAVONTE WILLIAMS.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT HIM AS RB-3,
I THINK WITH THE NUMBERS YOU SEE
HERE IN COLLEGE AND THE
OPPORTUNITY IN DENVER ARE, HE
SHOULD BE THE GUY THERE.
CONSIDERING HIM AN RB-3 TO OPEN
THE SEASON WITH THE ARROW
POINTING UP.
AND FINALLY, A TEAM I'M NOT
QUITE AS EXCITED ABOUT, AND
OFTEN YOU WANT TO STAY AWAY FROM
BAD TEAMS BUT THERE SEEMS TO BE
A MAJOR OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR
RUNNING BACK ROOKIE MICHAEL
CARTER OF THE NEW YORK JETS.
RB-28TH FOR ME, 57TH OVERALL.
TEVON COLEMAN, YOU HAVE INJURIES
AT THE WIDE RECEIVER GROUP, CORY
DAVIS COMING OVER.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THE NEW
YORK JETS TEAM.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE SUPER
EXCITED ABOUT A RUNNING BACK
LIKE THIS.
THE RECEIVING NUMBERS ARE
SOMEWHAT ENCOURAGING ON A TEAM
THAT MAY NOT BE THAT GOOD.
SO HE CAN CATCH PASSES THERE.
BUT, I THINK MICHAEL CARTER WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE BACKFIELD,
NOTHING SPECIAL THERE.
A NAME TO KEEP AN EYE ON, OF THE
ROOKIES.
THOSE ARE THE ROOKIES THAT
LANDED IN MY TOP 100 THESE
RANKINGS WILL ADJUST THROUGH THE
PRESEASON.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE ROOKIE
QUESTIONS HERE BEFORE WE MOVE TO
SOME NEW FACES AND NEW PLACES.
>>> OKAY ON, WHO IS THE JAGUARS
RUNNING BACK TO DRAFT AND COUNT
ON.
I HAVE NTN AT 22 AND ROBINSON AT
32.
AS WE SEE PRESEASON, WE WILL SEE
WHO IS SHAKING OUT, WHO IS
PLAYING WITH THE FIRST TEAM, ARE
THEY MIXING BOTH PLAYERS IN?
I THINK THAT IS WHAT IS GOING
HAPPEN.
ROBINSON DID A GOOD JOB AND CAME
OUT OF NOWHERE LAST YEAR AND HE
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY.
HOWEVER, IT DID NOT STOP THE
JAGUARS FROM TAKING TRAVIS
ENTIEN, IT COULD BE A SPLIT FOR
TOUCHES EARLY ON.
HE IS THE GUY TO HAVE.
BUT THE DRAFT IS NOT EVERYTHING
ANYMORE.
WAIVER WIRE IS IMPORTANT.
KEEP AN EYE ON BOTH PLAYERS.
LET'S MOVE TO ANOTHER QUESTION.
NOT ONLY ARE A LOT OF YOU
PLAYING IN YOUR REGULAR REDRAFT
LEAGUES AND YOUR DYNASTY LEAGUES
AND BATTLE HAWK SAID IN A
DYNASTY LEAGUE, WHICH ROOKIE
RUNNING BACK HAS THE MOST
FANTASY UP SIDE?
I WILL SAY IT IN A GENERAL
THOUGHT WHEN IT COMES TO DYNASTY
LEAGUES.
YOU SHOULD NOT BE THINKING MORE
THAN TWO OR THREE YEARS AHEAD.
THERE'S SO MUCH TURNOVER IN THE
NFL, I MEAN, WE ARE GOING TO GET
TO NEW FACES AND NEW PLACES.
LOOK WHERE DE'ANDRE HOPKINS IS
AND WAS, SAME WITH JULIO.
IT TURNS OVER QUICKLY, FOR
LANCE, YES, HE IS INSIDE MY TOP
12 IS GAROPPOLO GOING TO BE THE
STARTER FOR THE WHOLE SEASON?
WILL HE BE A WEEK ONE STARTER?
IT'S A FANTASY FRIENDLY OF
L.
IF TREY LANCE GETS OUT THERE AND
THE OPPORTUNITY IS THERE, AND I
THINK IT WILL BE THERE THIS YEAR
AT SOME POINT.
IT COMES BACK TO KYLE SHANAHAN,
A FANTASY FRIENDLY COACH.
>>> IS PITTS GOING TO SYPHON OFF
FROM JULIO?
>> HERE ARE THE NUMBERS OF A GUY
THAT WE WERE NOT TALKING MUCH
ABOUT COMING IN.
YES, RIDLEY IS THE MAN.
I LIKE PITTS AND I TOLD YOU
ABOUT THAT, AND IF I DID NOT
GIVE YOU THE NUMBER FOUR, PITTS
IS TIGHT END 5 AND 53rd OVERALL.
SO I LIKE HIM A LOT.
IT'S STILL A PASS FIRST TEAM.
YES, PITTS AND CALVIN ARE THE
BIGGEST BENEFACTORS FROM NO MORE
JULIO THERE, BUT CALVIN HAD 7.6
A GAME.
IF PITTS OR RIDLEY GOES WELL
ARROW POINTS HIGHER.
A SLEEPER.
MOVING ON FROM THAT ONE.
LET'S GET BACK TO THE ROOKIES.
WHERE SHOULD I DRAFT HARRIS?
SO, TO ME, I LOOK AT HIM, SAY IN
A 12 TEAM LEAGUE AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE SECOND ROUND AND TOP OF
THE THIRD.
LET ME GIVE YOU A WONDERFUL SPOT
FOR NAJA HARRIS.
IF YOU PICK IN THE FIRST THREE
SPOTS AND YOU END UP WITH A
MCCAFFERY OR A IDENTDAL DALVIN
ZEKE AND YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
BOARD AND NAJA HARRIS IS THERE.
HE IS MY RB-13.
THAT'S THE TOP OF THE RB-2
CATEGORY.
IF YOU OPEN UP WITH A BIG TIME
SUPER STAR RUNNING BACK.
IF YOU GET HIM THERE AND THEN
MAYBE A TEAM THAT MET UP WITH A
DJ METCALF AND ALLEN ROBINSON ON
THE TURN.
IT'S A GOOD START TO ME.
SO, LET'S SAY BOTTOM OF THE
SECOND.
TOP OF THE THIRD.
I'M VERY MUCH IN BEST PLAYER
AVAILABLE MODE WHEN IT COMES TO
RUNNING BACKS, WIDE RECEIVERS
AND TIGHT ENDS IN THE FIRST FOUR
ROUNDS.
WE WILL GET TO MORE QUESTIONS
COMING UP IN A BIT.
I TOLD YOU, WE WILL GET TO NEW
FACES IN NEW PLACES AND LET'S
MOVE TO THAT NOW.
MAJOR WIDE RECEIVERS.
JULIO JONES.
THIS IS WHAT HE DID THIS YEAR.
HE MISSED TIME, HE IS BANGED UP
COMING OVER THE TENNESSEE TITANS
AND JULIO, TO ME, IS A LUXURY
PLAYER FOR THE TENNESSEE TITANS.
YOU HAVE A.J.
ABLY A GREAT QUARTERBACK IN RYAN
TANNEHILL .
SO, JULIO TO ME, IT'S REALITY
COMING UP.
DE'ANDRE HOPKINS AND HE HAS GONE
WEST.
HE IS A MEMBER OF THE CARDINALS.
AND LOOK, HE IS PLAYED WITH
DESHAWUN WATSON, HE HAS PLAYED
WITH LESSER TALENTED NUMBERS.
AND NOW, HE COMES OVER TO
ARIZONA, HE IS WIDE RECEIVER 4.
AND 13 OVERALL ON THE BOARD.
KYLER MURRAY, A YOUNG
QUARTERBACK.
IT MAKES HIM MORE VALUABLE.
AND THE COLLEGE AND PRO RANKS.
>>> A.J. GREEN HAS COME OVER, TO
ME, YOIT FELT OVER RATED, HOPKI
COMES IN TO A GOOD SITUATION AND
YOU SHOULD FEEL JUST AS GOOD
ABOUT HIM AS YOU HAVE IN
PREVIOUS YEARS WITH THE HOUSTON
TEXANS.
>>> LET'S MOVE TO THE ATLANTA
FAL
FALCONS.
YO
WE TALKED ABOUT HIM A LOT.
THE CHANGE IN THE BACK FIELD IS
MIKE DAVIS, NOW, MIKE DAVIS, IF
YOU HAVE HAD MCCAFFERY ON YOUR
ROSTER AND GRABBED DAVIS.
HE KEPT YOU AFLOAT, HE WAS A
NICE HANDCUFF FOR MccAFFERY.
HE STEPS IN AN ATLANTA BACKFIELD
WHERE HE IS THE GUY.
THERE'S NOT MUCH BEHIND MIKE
DAVIS.
NOBODY OF NOTE.
WE KNOW WHAT HE DID LAST YEAR
FOR MCCAFFERY, AND YOU LOOK AT
ATLANTA AND YOU SAY, THEY ARE
NOT THAT GOOD.
HE CAN CATCHES PASSES.
52nd OVERALL, A PERFECT RB-3, IF
YOU HAVE HIM AT RB-2, BECAUSE
YOU WAIT ON THE RUNNING BACK
SPOT, IT MAKES SENSE, HE IS A
SOLID RUNNING BACK AND A PROVEN
ONE FOR FANTASY AS WE SAW LAST
YEAR.
>>> NOW, LET'S GO OUT WEST AND
TALK ABOUT MATTHEW STAFFORD.
SO, IS THIS MORE ABOUT MATTHEW
STAFFORD'S VALUE ON THE RISE?
OR HELPING THE RAMS IN GENERAL?
I THINK IT'S A LITTLE OF BOTH.
MUCH LIKE KYLE SHANAHAN THEIR
SAN FRANCISCO, YOU TALK ABOUT
McVEY AS A FANTASY FRIENDLY
COACH.
A GUY THAT KNOWS WHAT HE IS
DOING.
AND A GUY THAT I THINK WE WILL
SEE THE EVIDENCE OF MORE, GOT A
LOT OUT OF JARED GOFF AND HE
WILL GET MORE OUT OF A MUCH
BETTER QUARTERBACK IN MATTHEW
STAFFORD.
AND STAFFORD TO ME, QB-12.
I PROBABLY WILL MOVE HIM UP.
I CAN SEE HIM CREEPING IN MY TOP
TEN.
YOU HAVE WOODS.
YOU HAVE CUPP THERE.
I LIKE EVERYTHING ABOUT THE
SITUATION.
HE IS NOT SOMEONE YOU HAVE TO
RUN OUT AND GET, I KNOW THE
ARROW WAS POINTING UP COMING
FROM DEARTROIT TO THE RAMS.
I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE TO DRAFT
HIM TOO EARLY.
IF HE IS SITTING THERE AND
THERE'S EIGHT OR NINE
QUARTERBACKS OFF THE BOARD.
YOU ARE IN THE TEN OR 11 SPOT,
I'M OKAY GETTING HIM BECAUSE THE
UP SIDE IS THERE.
WE ARE FINALLY GOING TO SEE
MATTHEW STAFFORD GET THE RESPECT
THAT HE DESERVES.
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ABOUT SOME OF THE PLAYERS
IN NEW SPOTS AND HOW IT MAY
AFFECT THEIR FANTASY VALUE, AND
JULIO KEEPS COMING BACK.
THOUGHTS ON JULIO?
I HAVE DECIDED TO NOT KEEP HIM
AND KEPT KEENAN ALLEN AND ALVIN
KAMARA, I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT
NOW, FOR 2021, I AGREE WITH THAT
MANEUVER.
I PROBABLY WOULD NOT HAVE SAID
THAT IN THE LAST TWO OR THREE
YEARS.
BUT I THINK IT DOES MAKE A LOT
OF SENSE.
>>> BECAUSE, ALLEN AND KAMARA,
KEENAN ALLEN AND KAMARA ARE THE
CLEAR TOP PASS OPTIONS IN THE
REPRESENTIVE OFFENSES.
KAMARA, HE IS A PROVEN FANTASY
SUPER STAR AND MICHAEL THOMAS IS
UP IN THE AIR WITH WAITING TO
GET HIS SURGERY, WHEN WILL HE
RETURN TO NEW ORLEANS SAINTS,
WHAT IS THE RELATIONSHIP LIKE
WITH SALEAN PA PEYTON AND THE
TEAM.
KAMARA WILL RACK UP THIS
TOUCHES.
AND I LIKE MURRAY AS WELL
BECAUSE THE SAINTS ARE NOT THAT
DEEP AND OH, BY THE WAY, DREW
BREES IS RETIRED.
SO, I LIKE KAMARA THERE, I HAVE
ALLEN AT WIDE RECEIVER, EXCUSE
ME, WIDE RECEIVER 11, 30th
OVERALL.
KAMARA TO ME IS A TOP FIVE
RUNNING BACK AND THE KEENAN
ALLEN NUMBERS, THE GUY THAT I
MARKED DOWN FOR 100 CATCHES.
I EXPECT IT TO HAPPEN AND I
THINK THAT WILL CONTINUE IN THE
OFFENSE AND YOU LIKE THE
SITUATION THERE WITH THE
CHARGERS.
BUT JULIO TO ME IS MORE OF A
QUESTION MARK.
HE IS A LUXURY.
YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S A RUN
FIRST OFFENSE AS WE KNOW WITH
DERRICK HENRY.
THEY HAVE A.J. BROWN THERE.
IT'S NOT A BAD SITUATION FOR
JULIO, HE IS BETTER IN REALITY
VERSE FANTASY TO ME.
WIDE RECEIVER 20.
NUMBER 8 OVERALL.
IT DOES SEEM TO BE THE LEAGUE
CONSENSUS.
>>> LET'S TALK INJURIES.
WE HAVE BROUGHT UP A COUPLE
ALREADY .
THESE ARE INJURIES WE WILL BE
MONITORING THROUGHOUT THE
PRESEASON.
HERE ARE THE BIGGEST NAMES THAT
ARE BEING TALKED ABOUT.
CARSON WENTZ.
DID NOT WORK OUT IN
PHILADELPHIA.
THEY MOVE ON, HE COMES TO INDY.
SEEMS LIKE A FRESH START.
THEN THE FOOT INJURY POPS UP.
THE TALK WAS 5-12 WEEKS.
NOW, ESPN, IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
DAYS, HE COULD BE ON TRACK FOR
WEEK ONE.
AND THAT WAS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
INFORMATION IN A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME.
I DON'T LOVE THE INDIANAPOLIS
COLTS REALLY AS A WHOLE.
AND I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW,
OTHER THAN JONATHAN TAYLOR, I
DON'T HAVE ANYBODY INSIDE MY TOP
100.
THAT'S AN INDIANAPOLIS COLT.
I THINK WE NEED TO WAIT AND SEE.
AND CARSON WENTZ IS IN PERFECT
HEALTH AND FEELING GOOD AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH HE PLAYED
ANYWAY, YOU NEEDED TO GET
EVERYONE IN TUNE AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND EVEN IF HE IS OUT THERE FOR
WEEK NUMBER ONE, IT'S GOING TO
TAKE SOME TIME FOR ALL OF THAT
CHEMISTRY TO DEVELOP.
I KNOW THEY HAVE HAD THE
OFF-SEASON ON.
BUT IT'S, IT'S NOT GIVING ME THE
BEST VIBES ABOUT THE
INDIANAPOLIS COLTS.
LET'S MOVE SOUTH AND TALK ABOUT
THE DALLAS COWBOYS AND TALK
ABOUT AMARI COOPER WITH HIS FOOT
INJURY.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR
AND CD LAMB IS REALLY GOOD
PLAYER, WE WILL TALK MORE ABOUT
HIM COMING UP.
YOU HAVE DAK PRESCOTT GETTING
ANOTHER MRI AND COMING OFF A
MAJOR LEG INJURY AND NOW THE
SHOULDER IS A CONCERN.
JAY GLAZER SAID THAT WAS A
BASEBALL INJURY.
SO YOU HAVE THE COOPER FOOT
INJURY.
YOU HAVE DAK NOT AT FULL
STRENGTH RIGHT NOW.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DALLAS COWBOYS AND IT DOES NOT
HAVE ME FEELING VERY GOOD.
THESE ARE SITUATIONS WE NEED TO
KEEP A CLOSE EYE ON.
IF YOU ARE HEARING POSITIVE
REPORTS COWBOYS PUT OUT THE
TWEET.
I DIDN'T FEEL GOOD WHEN I SAW
THAT.
THEY WERE TRYING SAY, NO, NO, NO
DARK CLOUD, EVERYTHING IS FINE.
IT DOES NOT SEEM LIKE EVERYTHING
IS FINE RIGHT NOW.
SITUATIONS WES NEED TO KEEP
MONITORING.
AS WE SHOULD FOR ANOTHER TEAM IN
THE NFC EAST, THAT IS THE NEW
YORK GIANTS AND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST OFF-SEASON ACQUISITIONS
IS THAT MAN RIGHT THERE, THAT IS
KENNY GOLLADAY AND HE CAME DOWN
WITH A HAMSTRING INJURY IN THE
LAST WEEK OR SO.
TISSUE INJURIES LIKE THIS, IT
CAN WORK OUT AND IT CANNOT WORK
OUT.
YOU KNOW, A NEW TEAM HERE, YOU
HAVE BARKLEY COMING BACK.
THAT ALL SEEMS GOOD.
HE IS GOOD TO GO.
BUT I HATE THESE KIND OF
INJURIES.
A WIDE RECEIVER ON A NEW TEAM
WITH A NEW QUARTERBACK WILL MISS
TIME NOW.
YOU HOPE THEY DON'T RUSH HIM
BACK.
LET'S KEEP AN EYE ON THIS ONE.
GALLADAY AS WE KNOW CAN PERFORM
WHEN HE IS ON HIS GAME.
BUT THIS IS A NEW SITUATION.
IT'S A MAKER OR BREAK SEASON FOR
DANIEL JONES AND GALLADAY WAS
BROUGHT IN TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
CAN HE DO SO?
WE WILL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE.
WE WILL KEEP A CLOSE A EYE ON
THE HAMSTRING INJURY.
LET'S THROW IN ONE MORE.
IT'S NOT A NEW INJURY.
IT'S AFFECTED THE FANTASY
BACKFIELD OF THE LOS ANGELES
RAMS.
THEY ARE SUFFERING A TORN
ACHILLES, HE IS OUT FOR THE
SEASON.
SO, DARROL ENH ENDERSON IS
INTRIGUING.
WHEN WE SAW HIM AS THE MAN, HE
DID A GOOD JOB.
CAN HE BE THE MAN FOR THE ENTIRE
SEASON?
THAT'S A QUESTION FOR ANY
RUNNING BACK AS WE KNOW.
BUT I THINK HE HAS PROVEN WHEN
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY, HE CAN
TAKE THE BALL AND RUN WITH IT
AND PUT UP FANTASY IS
PRODUCTION.
TO ME HE IS A TOP 20 RUNNING
BACK.
I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD GO
OVERB
OVERBOARD, BUT IT OPENS UP A
MAJOR OPPORTUNITY AND STAFFORD
SHOULD TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY AS A
WHOLE.
BARKLEY ORC KAMARA, I HAVE KAMAA
5, AND BARKLEY 6.
IT'S BACK-TO-BACK.
BARKLEY COMING OFF OF A TORN
ACL, DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A REAL
CONCERN ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW HE CAN FILL UP THE STAT
SHEET, RUNNING THE BALL,
CATCHING THE BALL.
I THINK THERE WILL BE MORE
SCORING OPPORTUNITY ON A BETTER
OFFENSE.
I JUST FEEL IN A PPR THAT KAMARA
IS GOING TO GET FAR MORE
TOUCHES, I THINK HE WILL GET
MORE CATCH OPPORTUNITIES, TARGET
OPPORTUNITIES, ON A TEAM THAT,
YOU KNOW, HAS A LOT OF QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW.
BUT ONE QUESTION THE SAINTS
DON'T HAVE IS KAMARA.
5-6, YOU ARE NOT GOING WRONG
WITH THOSE TWO GUYS.
>>> SPEAKING OF RUNNING BACKS,
WE WILL BE REVEALING THE
RANKINGS OVER THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS.
WE WILL DO IT RIGHT NOW, WITH
THE RUNNING BACK POSITION.
WHERE DO I HAVE THE TOP FIVE
RUNNING BACKS?
WE WILL START WITH MCCAFFERY.
YES, HE MISSED TIME LAST YEAR.
AND A LOT OF THESE ARE GOING TO
COME DOWN TO RUNNING BACKS IN
GREAT SITUATIONS.
MCCAFFERY IS THE MAN.
HE IS A PROVEN MAN FOR THE
CAROLINA PANTHERS.
HE IS SOMEONE THAT YOU GO, IF HE
HAD 100 CATCHES YOU WOULD NOT BE
SURPRISED.
THAT TEAMS RIDICULOUS.
BUT, THEY NEED HIM.
HE WILL GET DUMP OFFS.
HE CAN RUN THE FOOTBALL.
HE CAN DO IT ALL FOR THE
CAROLINA PANTHERS, TOO MUCH
OPPORTUNITY THERE TO IGNORE FOR
MCCAFFERY.
HE IS MY RB-1 FOR THE SEASON.
I THINK THIS IS WHERE QUESTIONS
COME IN.
WHERE DO YOU GO FROM HERE?
I WILL SAY, IT'S CLOSE AND
NITPICKY TO PICK BETWEEN THE
PLAYERS BUT DALVIN COOK.
DALVIN COOK WILL COME UP AS
SOMEBODY YOU SAY, HOW ABOUT
INJURIES?
DALVIN COOK AS WE SAW LAST YEAR
IS GREAT.
THERE'S QUESTIONS OF COUSINS AND
HOW MUCH THEY WANT TO RELY ON
HIM AND YES, YOU HAVE DIGGS AND
WHEN DIGGS WAS GONE LAST YEAR,
YES, THEY GOT JUSTIN JEFFERSON
AND THAT WAS HUGE.
BUT COOK WAS THAT MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT.
HE IS READY TO GO TO ME.
HE CAN FILL UP THE STAT SHEET AS
WELL, WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT,
THE VIKING, IT'S MIKE ZIMMER
EVEN THOUGH HE IS A DEFENSIVE
GUY, THEY ARE GOING RELY ON THE
RUN.
>>> LET'S MOVE TO NUMBER THREE,
EZEKIEL ELLIOTT.
WE HAVE ASKED ABOUT THE
QUESTIONS OF THE INJURIES AT THE
COWBOYS.
WHEN THEY ARE IN DOUBT, THEY
FALL BACK ON HIM.
HE WILL DO IT ALL, HE WILL CATCH
IT AND RUN THE BALL WELL.
HE WILL GET THE BALL TO THE GOAL
LINE.
AND ALL OF THE THINGS FOR THE
COWBOYS, IF QUESTIONS ARISE,
THEY HAVE ZEEK, HE IS RB-3, HE
IS A EASY SELECTION.
WE WILL GET THE OTHER NAME AND
YOU SAY MAY SAY, WELL, WHERE IS
DERRICK HENRY?
HENRY IS NUMBER 4.
IF YOU SAID I'M TAKING HENRY
OVER COOK, I WILL NOT GIVE YOU
THAT.
BUT I WILL POINT OUT THE NUMBERS
FOR THE RECEIVING NUMBERS.
HE IS NOT GOING TO CATCH THE
BALL.
DERRICK HENRY HAS NEVER GOTTEN
HIS FANTASY PRODUCTION FROM
CATCHING THE BALL.
ANY TIME HE DOES ANYTHING IN THE
PASSING GAME IT'S A BONUS.
HE MAY BE THE BEST PURE RUNNING
BACK IN THE LEAGUE AND THAT GOES
A LONG WAY ON A RUN FIRST TEAM.
NOW, THEY HAVE ADDED JULIO
JONES.
YOU STILL HAVE A.J. BROWN.
AND PEOPLE SAY, WITH H
-
WILL OPEN IT UP MORE AND HE WILL
GET MORE OUT OF THE CARRIES.
HE IS POWERFUL, HE IS EFFICIENT.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN RELY ON HIM.
IF TOUYOU WANT TO TAKE HIM AT 3
2, THAT SAYS PLENTY.
A PLAYER THAT IS VETERAN REALITY
VERSE FANTASY, AND THAT IS ONLY
BECAUSE HE DOES NOT CHAATCH THE
BALL, AND THE TITANS TO NOT NEED
TO USE HIM IN THAT SPOT OFTEN.
>>> NUMBER FIVE IS ALVIN KAMARA.
HE CAN DO EVERYTHING FOR THE
SAINTS.
I WILL SAY, I THINK MURRAY WILL
GET A FEW EXTRA CARRIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY DON'T OVERWORK
KAMARA.
BUT KAMARA WILL GET 15 CARRIES
AND HE WILL GET TARGETS.
THAT WILL CONTINUE REGARDLESS OF
WHAT HAPPENS WITH MICHAEL
THOMAS, AND IF THEY CAN DEVELOP
THE OTHER PLAYERS AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT EVER THEY ARE DOING AT THE
QUARTERBACK SPOT.
BUT KAMARA IS GOING DO DO
EVERYTHING THAT THE SAINTS NEED
JUST OUT OF NECESSITY.
I DON'T WORRY ABOUT HIM, THE
INJURIES LAST YEAR, WE KNOW.
BUT LOOK, THE TOUCHDOWNS WERE
THERE.
HE IS SOMEONE WHO ALSO WHEEILE T
AS BIG AS MURRAY WILL FILL UP
THE STAT SHEET.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITHA
KAMARA.
BARKLEY IS 6 AND NOT FAR OFF.
>>> LET'S GET TO A BUNCH OF
QUESTIONS AS YOU HAVE BEEN
FEEDING THEM THROUGHOUT THE WEEK
AND TODAY ON THE BR APP, CWI,
I'M IN A KEEPER LEAGUE, WHO DO I
KEEP?
JONATHAN TAYLOR OR I LOSE MY
THIRD ROUND PICK.
WALL I LOSE MY FOURTH ROUND AND
CD LAMB OR LOSE MY 9TH ROUND
PICK?
I LIKE TO HELP EVERYONE OUT.
TAYLOR MY RB-10.
AND LAMB ON WIDE RECEIVER 12,
32nd OVERALL.
THESES ARE ALL GREAT VALUES TO
ME.
BUT IF I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
NUMBER 10 TIGHT END, AND SOMEONE
WHO I WOULD TAKE IN THE FIRST 14
PICKS.
IF I CAN GET HIM IN THE THIRD
ROUND, I WOULD PROBABLY WANT TO
GO THERE.
IF YOU WANT TO SAY THE VALUE OF
CD LAMB IS UNBELIEVABLE.
I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
IF YOU SAY I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT
RUNNING BACK I WILL GET ONE IN
THE FIRST ROUND AND MOVE ON FROM
THERE.
THAT'S FINE.
I WILL MIX AND MATCH, I WILL DO
IT AS WELL.
I LIKE TO GET A RUNNING BACK IN
THE FIRST TWO ROUNDS AND THEM
I'M UNDERSTANDING THE SECOND
RUNNING BACK SPOT IS NOT GOING
TO BE A CONSISTENT ROLE.
I'M GOING TO DEAL WITH INJURIES.
I'M GOING TO DEAL WITH CHANGES
IN TERMS OF ROLE.
SO IF YOU WANT TO SAY THE VALUE
OF CD LAMB IS TOO GOOD.
GO AHEAD.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
AS I SAID, SOMETIMES YOU TAKE
THEM IN A VACUUM.
I'M GETTING JONATHAN TAYLOR IN
THE THIRD ROUND, IT'S A WIN TO
ME.
NONE OF THOSE SPOTS ARE BAD.
>>> JAM IN THE HAM, WITH A DEEP
WIDE RECEIVER POOL, IS IT IS
SMART TO DRAFT TARGET RUNNING
BACKS AT THE TOP OF THE DRAFT?
SO, YES, MY TOP 25 HAS NINE WIDE
RECEIVERS, 14 RUNNING BACKS AND
TWO TIGHT ENDS.
BECAUSE I THINK THERE ARE GAME
CHANGERS AT RUNNING BACK LIKE
MCCAFFERY, BARKLEY, ZEEK, AND
COOK AND KAMARA.
IF I GET ONE EARLY, IT MAY GIVE
ME LESS OF A REASON TO TAKE A
RUNNING BACK IN THE SECOND OR
THIRD ROUND.
I STILL THINK YOU ARE IN BEST
PLAYER AVAILABLE MODE.
BUT I DO THINK THE WIDE RECEIVER
GROUP AS A WHOLE FROM IN TERMS
OF TOP TEAR TALN'T IS DEEPER.
SO, I DO LIKE GETTING THE
RUNNING BACK EARLY.
INJURIES CAN HAPPEN TO ANYBODY.
BUT THE WIDE RECEIVER GROUP IS
DEEPER.
LET'S MOVE TO NASTY BIRD.
I'M IN A KEEPER LEAGUE BETWEEN
ADAMS AND COOK, WHO SHOULD I
COOP -- WHO SHOULD I KEEP?
I WILL GO COOK THERE, AND ADAMS
A LOT OF QUESTION MARKS UNTIL A
FEW WEEKS AGO.
WE KNOW AARON RODGERS IS PLAYING
QUARTERBACK, AND I WOULD GO
COOK, I HAVE HIM SECOND OVERALL.
I DON'T THINK THAT YOU ARE GOING
TO GO WRONG HEEFRMT BECRE, BECA
WIDE RECEIVER GROUP IS DEEPER, I
WILL TAKE COOK.
>>> I HAVE ZEEK AT 3, THIRD AT
RUNNING BACK, THIRD OVERALL.
I HAVE ECKLER AT RB-8, AND CHUBB
AT RB-9 OVERALL.
ECKLER IS IMPORTANT TO THE
CHARGER OFFENSE.
WHERE ARE THEY AT AT RUNNING
BACK?
DO THEY HAVE ANYBODY THEY
FRUST
TRUST?
I DON'T THINK SO.
CHUBB IS GETTING AN EXTENSION
FROM A GOOD TEAM NO SECRET, THE
BROWNS ARE ONE OF THE BEST TEAMS
IN THE NFL.
LET ME REPEAT THAT, THE BROWNS
ARE ONE OF THE BEST TEAMS IN THE
NFL.
CHUBB IS A BIG PART OF IT.
I WILL TAKE ECKLER HIGHER, WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE WEAPONS FOR THE
CHARGERS, ECKLER IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN CHUBB.
IT'S NITPICK YOU ARE NOT IN A
BAD SPOT IN ANY OF THEMP.
>>> SHOULD I TAKE J.K. DOBBINS
19TH OVER INSTALL TO ME, DOBBINS
HIGH THERE.
28TH OVERALL.
IT'S TOO EARLY TO KNOW IF HE
WILL BE THE LEAD.
I THINK HE WILL BE.
YOU J LAMAR JACKSON THAT WILL
RUN.
AND YOU SAMMY WATKINS.
IT'S A RUN FIRST TEAM.
IT'S EARLY TO ME, BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO SAY WITH 100%
CONFIDENCE THAT IT'S DOBBINS AND
DON'T WORRY ABOUT ANYBODY ELSE.
THEY WILL USE ONE, TWO, THREE
RUNNING BACKS THE NUMBERS WERE
GOOD LAST YEAR AND WE WILL
ALWAYS SEE OTHERS GET INVOLVED
IN THE RUN FIRST OFFENSE THAT IS
HOW THEY OPERATE.
DO THEY NEED TO PASS MORE?
DO THEY NEED TO PASS MORE
EFFICIENCY?
ABSOLUTELY THEY DO.
BUT, BECAUSE THEY HAVE MULTIPLE
PLAYERS THAT THEY CAN GO TO THE
GROUND, INCLUDING THEIR
QUARTERBACK, I THINK TAKING
DOBBINS AT 19 IS A BIT TOO
EARLY.
>>> LET'S MOVE TO ANOTHER ONE
HERE.
I THINK IT'S SUNAM, SHOULD I, AM
I REACHING TO MUCH FOR TAKING
DARROL HENDERSON.
HALF POINT, 12 TEAM LEAGUE,
SNAKE DRAFT.
40TH OVERALL PUTS HIM WHERE?
IN THE FOURTH ROUND?
IT'S A BIG EARLY.
I LIKE THE RAMS' OFFENSE, I
THINK WHEN YOU SEE WHEN
HENDERSON HAS GOTTEN CHANCES HE
HAS BEEN PRODUCTIVE.
CAN HE BE THE GUY FOR THE ENTIRE
SON?
THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION.
WHEN IN DOUBT, YOU SAY HE IS ON
A GOOD TEAM?
YES.
AND STAFFORD MAKES THEM BETTER.
BUT IT'S A BIT TOO EARLY.
TO ME, HE IS PROBABLY MORE OF A
MIDDLE OF THE FOURTH ROUND PICK.
I THINK YOU ARE JUST GOING A
LITTLE BIT EARLY ON SOMEONE LIKE
DARROL HENDERSON.
I'M LOOKING AT BETTER PLAYERS
AVAILABLE AT WIDE RECEIVER OR
MAYBE SOMEBODY WITH WALLER AT
THE TIGHT END POSITION.
LET'S GET TO ANOTHER QUESTION
HERE AS WE START TO WIND DOWN
AND THIS IS FROM THE ZONE, GUS
EDWARDS, MURRAY OR WILLIAMS?
A PPR LEAGUE.
I SEE POSITIVES IN ALL THE
PLAYERS.
GUS EDWARDS, RB-37, 84TH EVERY
ON ALL.
LA
MURRAY, I COULD MOVE HIM UP AS
WE LEARN MORE ABOUT MICHAEL
THOMAS AND THOMAS, 110 OVERALL.
YOU SEE WHAT GUS EDWARDS DID
LAST YEAR, IT ANNOYED?
SOME PEOPLE, MURRAY WITH THE
SAINTS HAVING SO MUCH TURNOVER,
QUESTIONS ABOUT MICHAEL THOMAS
AND YOU KNOW YOU WILL FEED
KAMARA ON THE GROUND AND THROUGH
THE AIR.
HE IS A NICE SOLID OPTION, RB-3,
TO START THE SEASON.
THAT COULD CHANGE.
I WILL GIVE YOU EARLY ADVICE
HERE.
LATAVIOUS MURRAY CAN GET TO ATH
THERE.
AND THOMAS COMES BACK AND HE MAY
BE A SELL HIGH GUY.
>>> I LEAN EDWARDS THERE.
PROBABLY FOR THE MAJORITY OF THE
SEASON.
ANOTHER ONE HERE FROM WHAM, I'M
IN A KEEPERS LEAGUE, I'M
DEBATING BETWEEN WALLER AND
GIVING UP MY FICHFTH ROUND AND D
ER SON AND GIVING UP THE 11TH
ROUND.
WHAT A YEAR WALLER HAD LAST YEAR
WITH THE LAS VEGAS RAIDERS.
HENDE
HENDERSON, THE VALUE IS HERE.
LET'S SEPARATE THE TWO.
THE VALUES FOR BOTH PLAYERS IS
OUTSTANDING.
BUT WHEN I'M TALKING ABOUT A
PLAYER THAT IS 40TH OVERALL.
WHO IS GIVING ME POSITION AT THE
TIGHT END POSITION.
AND I THINK I JUST TAKE WALLER
THERE IN THE 5TH.
I GO BEST PLAYER AVAILABLE.
BUT BOTH VALUES ARE ABSOLUTELY
FANTASTIC.
>>> I LEAN WALLER WITH THAT ONE.
LET'S TRY TO SNEAK ON ANOTHER
COUPLE AS WE WIND DOWN.
AARON JONES OR JT, I ASSUME YOU
MEAN JONATHAN TAYLOR.
RODGERS BACK, ADAMS BACK, I LIKE
AARON JONES AND I'M WORRIED
ABOUT DILLON ON.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT I LIKE THE SITUATION IN
GREEN BAY.
I HAVE JONES A FEW SPOTS HIGHER
THAN JONATHAN TAYLOR.
>>> BRAD HERE, TEN TEAM CENTER
SCORING.
KEEPER LEAGUE, DO I KEEP HOPKINS
AND AARON JONES?
IF YOU CAN KEEP THEM BOTH YES,
IF I'M RANKING THEM I GO HOPKINS
A BIT HIGHER.
BUT BOTH SPOTS ARE GOOD IF AND
YOU ARE STARTING THE TEN TEAMER
OFF WITH TWO BONAFIDE, RB-1,
WIDE RECEIVER ONES IN THOSE
CATEGORIES.
YOU ARE GOING DO.
>>> HIGHER UP SIDE, KEENAN
ALLEN, THE ANSWER IS ALLEN FOR
BOTH.
YOU LOCK ALLEN DOWN FOR 100
CATCHES.
I HOPE RYAN FITZPATRICK IS THE
STARTING QUARTERBACK FOR THE
TEAM IN WASHINGTON FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THE SEASON BECAUSE
HE IS FANTASY FRIENDLY.
BUT I TRUST KEENAN ALLEN MORE,
SO I WILL GO KEENAN ALLEN ON
THAT ONE.
LET'S SEE, NEXT ONE.
DANNY, ARE YOU BUYING ZACH
WILSON AS A LATE ROUND
QUARTERBACK OPTION?
HE WILL HAVE WEAPONS.
YEAH, I, LOOK, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
A SPOT LIKE THAT, YOU SAY LATE
ROUND.
BUT WILL I NEED THE ROSTER SPOT
IN A BEST OF ALL LEAGUE?
YES, THROW HIM IN AND HE THE IN
THE LINEUP.
BUT IF I'M TAKING A LATE ROUND
QUARTERBACK AND I AM GOING TO
EXTREME MY QUARTERBACKS.
IF I HAVE SOMEBODY I TRUST.
I WILL GO WITH THAT GUY, AND
WHEN I NEED TO FIX SOMEBODY ELSE
UP, I WILL.
IN A BEST BALL, SURE, THROW HIM
IN AND MAYBE GET A COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
ANOTHER ONE IN HERE.
JON TAN TAYLOR, BE EFFECTIVE
NEGATIVELY TO START WITH THE
INJURY TO FEDERNELSON AND WENTZ?
MAC IS PROBABLY A THORN IN YOUR
SIDE AS WE DEALT WITH THE
JONATHAN TAYLOR.
BUT EARLY ON, YEAH, I THINK
THERE'S QUESTION MARKS WITH
JONATHAN TAYLOR AND MIGHT I ADD,
IF HE IS SOMEONE WHO IS
STRUGGLING EARLY, HE MIGHT BE A
BUY LOW CANDIDATE.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S SEE IF WE CAN
GET A COUPLE OTHER ONES IN HERE.
WEEK ONE QUESTIONS HERE.
LET ME MAKE THIS CLEAR.
WE ARE NOT EVEN IN SEPTEMBER
YET.
YOU ARE NOT SETTING LINEUP-S IN
WEEK ONE BEFORE IT'S SEPTEMBER
IS.
YOU ARE NOT SETTING THE LINEUPS
UNTIL TWO DAYS BEFORE THAT
THURSDAY NIGHT GAME BETWEEN
DALLAS AND TAMPA BAY.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
A LOT IS GOING TO HAPPEN BETWEEN
NOW AND WEEK NUMBER ONE AND
GUESS WHAT I WILL BE WITH YOU
HERE FOR THE NEXT THREE
THURSDAYs, 1:00 P.M. EASTERN ON
THE BR-APP, COVERING FANTASY
FOOTBALL FOR BR-GRID IRON, MAKE
SURE TO KEEP GET YOUR QUESTIONS
IN.
YOU CAN FIND ME ON TWITTER AND
INSTAGRAM,@THE MATT CAMP, GET
THEM IN THE APP AND I WILL
ANSWER MORE NEXT WEEK.
WE WILL HAVE MORE RANKINGS AND
INJURIES AND EVERYTHING TO TALK
ABOUT COMING OFF THE FIRST FULL
WEEK OF PRESEASON ACTION.
I WILL SEE YOU NEXT THURSDAY,
RIGHT HERE, AT 1:00 P.M. EASTERN
ON YOUR FANTASY FIRE DRILL.